I am offering you now a chance at the
experience of a lifetime
what alive a freak one minute you
playing twenty-one and horse on the
courts in Harlem in the next moment
you're in the showroom ladies and
gentlemen please welcome the next NBA
superstar frequency vibrations from mine
these fools were you wrong
what precinct this is the right move
this is the right move now
got everything don't you for you what I
have nothing then I got nothing
this is not a request I am NOT asking
you to do this
I am telling you to do this you got to
do what you got to do when you need to
do it and I've given this team
everything I got I practice hard I play
hard we need to strike while the iron is
fine this is your life you will be up
there with all the big names we should
think I realized that I have vultures or
bless I can leeches in my life don't
think I realize that you're one of them
you got all this because of Ray and
don't you ever forget that
so what's the next move the next move is
freaks it always has been
question is is he ready and willing to
do what needs to be done
you